hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
or manga and today we are here to talk
about the promised Neverland so I've
recently watched this little series and
I know I'm late to the party but I'm
almost always late to the party so
whatever in any case I do think this
series demands to be talked about before
I say anything whatsoever though I would
like to put out a huge spoiler warning
because it is next to impossible to
discuss this series in any way without
revealing major plot points at every
turn and if this is something you were
considering watching or reading my
recommendation would be to go into it as
blindly as possible however if you're
still keen to continue well I'm not your
real mother so do as you like
so what I will say from the outset is
that I went into the promised Neverland
with zero expectations and I suspect
that played a big part in how much of a
favorable impact it had on me the series
is well paced with a gripping cast of
characters and a really solid hook in
terms of the narrative and let's start
with the general premise because why not
so as I was watching the first episode
it was pretty painfully clear that
everything at the grace-filled house was
not as it seemed but to say that I was
expecting to Monica agriculture would be
an absolute lie its premise that I
really enjoy well I don't know if enjoy
is the right word but something that
immediately captivated me because it
sets up a fascinating dynamic between
the children at the orphanage and there
would be farmers which is that they
can't simply kill the kids who are being
troublesome to their plants because they
are highly valued stock and that sets
into motion a nicely unique series of
events that evolves into more of a
battle of wits then what is initially
presented as a thriller perhaps even a
horror piece however that sinister
nature is always overwhelmingly present
embedded within each and every
storytelling device that the anime has
access to one of the things I really
love about the promised Neverland is how
visually distinct it is in regards to
shock composition and editing editing in
particular frequently takes advantage of
jarring cuts to elicit truly unnerving
responses and one of the best examples I
can think of is in episode 2 which went
from a shot of Emma to a shot of Norman
and when he peeked around the corner
there was an immediate cut to mother
standing with Emma and legitimately jump
scared the crap out of me it was
fantastic and there were a plethora of
other well employed visual techniques
that really added an air of tension and
just plain weirdness kind of like the
tendency to have a close-up shot on a
character's neck while they were
speaking really highlighting their
number as well as the fact that they are
more of a product than they are people
in this world plus there were other
great classic tension building shots
like all the first person perspective
walking through hallway moments each and
every one of them had me convinced the
jumps
was imminent because that's how
effectively they filled the atmosphere
with creepy pressure although I will say
that I'm glad that the series did not
try to sustain that feeling of horror
throughout and instead opted to explore
tension in its various forms and you
know when I think about it I'm not
really sure what genre I would throw the
promise Neverland into because over its
12-episode run it seemed to cover at
least four different genres to me the
first of which was that horror thriller
aspect of the early episodes but then
that kind of subsided and it turned into
more of a mind game style series
somewhat akin to Death Note but then it
radically shifted again into a more
depressing tale of fate within the
system and then finally it turned into a
good old-fashioned to break out story
and I have nothing but praise for how
the series shifted so seamlessly through
these various ideas especially since the
entire thing is condensed into a very
simple single location it was a superb
show of artistry from the production
team the actors and I'm assuming the
original source material as well in the
manga as for the characters despite the
fact that we have an orphanage full of
what thirty eight children and two
adults at most at any given time primary
focus was only given to a handful of
individuals which i think is a great
choice by the end of these twelve
episodes no fundamental character felt
undercooked and they did chant a solid
amount of development plus the fact that
we really didn't expand on the other
orphans at all with a few exceptions of
course made the eventual climax of the
series all the better when we saw
flashbacks of them all training for the
escape which had been taking place in
the background while our focus was
elsewhere it was really satisfying and
of course my favorite character was
definitely Emma she's instantly likable
because of a kind and idealistic nature
but after the first couple of episodes I
do remember being really worried that
she would become the relentless optimist
who would continue to insist on having
her ideals met and I was pleasantly
surprised to throughout the run Emmit
developed and matured significantly to
the point where she amended her original
idea of having all of the kids escape
but without losing any of her core
values as she bound to return for those
they had left behind it was also really
impressive that she was so mentally
capable of dealing with the situations
that's presented to her i think emma is
one of those characters who at first
glance is easy to write off as a bit of
an airhead a lovely person but not the
kind of character who you know handles
the thinking and I love just how wrong
that thought of mine ended up being and
yes I know it's established from the
very beginning that she's one of the
smartest kids in the facility but that
wasn't how she generally presented
herself outside of a classroom which
made her moments of exceptional thinking
all the more
in regards to the idea of thinking
though I will say that there were times
within the promised Neverland where it
really pushed the idea of how
intelligent these kids are to the very
extreme given that they were all under
12 years old kind of complexity coming
from them was absolutely insane
especially when it came to things like
gray being able to build a device that
disables their trackers that in
particular was a bit hard to buy because
I know that these kids gifted but
they've lived on what is more or less
farmland actually quite literally
farmland I guess with no access to any
form of advanced technology outside of
what Ray brought in as his prizes but
even with that there would be assumedly
no reasonable source of knowledge or
tools to put such a thing together and I
guess it's not series breaking and I
know that Ray does have a particularly
godlike memory but it does require that
extra suspension of disbelief and of
course there's also fill'd it was a four
year old boy and quite possibly the most
naturally intelligent character within
the entire series it's completely absurd
but phil is just so damn adorable that
he gets away with it
but all in all I do have to give more
high praise to how well the kids were
written as characters it is such a
difficult thing to write kids for a
teenage or even worse an adult audience
because generally you have two choices
you can either make them really smart
thus garnering the hatred of adults who
see the child as an inconceivable genius
type you know the Wesley Crusher effect
oh you write them as realistic kids in
which case adults take little to no
interest in them because they have very
little depth they're always predictable
and they won't generally be capable of
contributing anything major to the story
due to their age and an experience the
promise Neverland has somehow managed to
avoid that issue even though the kids in
the show embodied both of those
theoretical problems at some points
being absurdly smart and at others being
incredibly simple and childlike yes I'm
looking at you
dawn however I don't think either of
those crossed into the realm of your
typical annoying child characters they
were all very nicely rounded and
compelling figures who I really got
behind for the duration of the series
there is one thing that did kind of
annoy me about syriza and it's how the
character of Norman is eventually dealt
with so here's the deal right there is
absolutely no way this kid is dead i
100% refuse to believe that his final
moments were being ushered into a
brightly lit room and being asked to
wait I would bet large quantities of
currency that he is live and will appear
again later down the line now this in
and of itself isn't so much of a problem
to me but rather how it impacted
juxtaposed moments for example the
entire episode leading up until the
point was simply heartbreaking with
Norman and the rest of the kids coming
to terms with the fact that there was
nothing they could do and that he was
going to be killed
watching Norman succumb to terror in the
bathroom but eventually bravely meeting
his end for the sake of helping the
other kids is such a beautiful and
tragic idea but what it turned into has
the potential to undercut that to me if
what I suspect is true and you know the
99.9% chance of him being alive turns
out to be accurate and I think it takes
away from the drama and focus put on his
brave decision to sacrifice himself it's
something that I really hate in all
forms of media making the idea of the
death of a character into a substantial
plot point only to bring them back later
and thus negate all of the drama you
took the time to create using their
quote-unquote death it's what really
annoys me about western comics as well
as sequels to movies in general who
boldly kill a character only to bring
them back for the sequel somehow because
they were popular and just to examine
the flipside for a second if Norman is
actually dead then this is a pathetic
final moment from a storytelling
perspective and it was a huge misstep
which I refused to believe because up
until this point everything felt so
sturdy to me also going further there
were some more beautiful moments during
the escape
Norman's present somewhat appeared as if
it was his final legacy being enacted
and that once again will be undercut if
it turns out that he was alive all along
but that is really the only thing that
came close to bothering me about the
promise Neverland otherwise it was a
ride that I was completely on board with
and I'm very keen to see more in the
future and may there is still so much
they haven't even touched on like the
great characters of Mother Isabella and
sister Crone with sister Crone in
particular she was an exceptionally
creepy presence for the majority of her
time in the series I think her voice
actor did a wonderful job of bringing
her to life as did the animators who
gave some nice delicate attention to her
eccentricities and I was very pleasantly
surprised when I actually came to feel
for her as a character right before she
was killed and it's not because of
anything she did she was a generally
terrible human being but it has
everything to do with her doll because
you know at first it seemed like sister
Crona had that deranged mother fantasy
which to be fair she kind of did but it
hit me so hard when we were showing that
that doll was actually her toy from when
she was raised to stock on one of the
human farms that incredibly simple
connection activated all of the fields
within me and I was genuinely sad when
she met her demise I can't really say I
ended up feeling the same way about
Isabella though as a character she fall
at the same sort of trajectory as
sister Kron starting out as a horrific
ly creepy presence and coming to be
somewhat redeemed and understood by the
end she was also a victim of the ways of
this world however she didn't have that
moment of sharply connecting to me like
sister Brian and I still very much
dislike Isabella but she know after
facilitating the murder of many many
children I think is quite fair she was
still the great character though and a
very imposing presence now there is a
further step here within the system
because we have sisters mothers and even
and grandmother who was hands down the
number one Creepo in the promise
Neverland and what I'm really hoping is
that if she does have an eventual arc it
doesn't follow the story of trying to
generate any sort of sympathy whatsoever
at the moment to me grandma is pretty
much the epitome of evil in the series
much more so than the demons could ever
be and I'd very much like her to remain
that way speaking of the demons though
I'm not entirely sure how to feel about
them part of me wishes that we hadn't
seen so much of them and they were kept
as a more mystified existence but I have
to admit that that would only work for
the story to a certain extent after
knowing how this anime series concluded
I do understand why it was a good idea
to introduce their physical forms very
clearly on-screen at an early stage
because I imagine that we're about to go
out into a world we're seeing them is
fairly commonplace and it might be a bit
jarring to have weird-looking demons be
a part of the series all of a sudden by
the way some real Tokyo when I first saw
the end of episode 1 I thought that
there were aliens I didn't realize there
were demons until one of the characters
actually said the word demon and then I
was like oh I am like I guess they could
also be demons but in conclusion the
romo stimulant was a very nice surprise
I'm glad I got to watch it all at once
because I'm honestly not sure that it
would have been as good an experience
waiting weakly but highly recommended to
all even those of you who haven't seen
it and are well and truly spoiled if
you've made it this far into the video
but that pretty much does it for my
thoughts on the promise Neverland if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produced in general then please
do consider donating to the new world -
via patreon because the support of all
the amazing people is what continues to
make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps
support the channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to main
discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan ray takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on the promised neverland
this has been the new world review and
I'll see you next time